[Music]
[Laughter]
we're going to talk about what the best
Jordan Peele character is of all time
last week we did the best key and Peele
sketch of all time and you guys let us
know in the comments that we missed a
couple but we're throwing out dr. Terry
they're throwing out substitute teachers
so keep an eye out for today's episode
of next week you might see some of those
sneaking in but today you're gonna see a
bunch of clips from Jordan Peele doing
his best characters and you know you've
made it like Jordan Peele has when
you've become a meme
check this out so this is him doing his
Obama impersonation and the Internet has
decided to add labels based on how he
treats the so he's won an Oscar you know
he may get out but this is really once
you become a meme you know you've made
it and show that headline Julian he's
gonna be hosting the Twilight Zone
revival he's also producing it I'm very
excited for this I'm a big Twilight Zone
head you guys excited for this are we
about the into I'm a huge scaredy-cat
like if I'm gonna see a horror movie I
have to read the entire plot before I
see it get out so I read the whole thing
before I saw it and I'm I'm gonna watch
it I have to read the whole thing
because otherwise I like yell too much I
like move too much in my seats the best
go to a black theatre because of the
black leader that is dead as wind they
say girl let it out that's about I just
saw not just but like a few months ago
saw hereditary and I was too scary too
scary I screamed I like a classic scream
when the things storied across the
ceiling I went
hopefully looked at me hereditary is so
scary that I have read the whole thing
and it's so like too scared I know
exactly
I know the senior referencing yeah can I
watch it I want to get into the clips
we're gonna talk about some Jordan Peele
Chris what you got first verse okay
there's a classic scene here man brings
women to club and she gets some beat up
yeah show me you're not projecting yeah
well once you give it to your new fat
ugly girlfriend Jackie
[Music]
how's that possible
I can't be an asshole I got arms legs
and a head I have two jackets you want
its now you know what why would I do
that you know what I'm not following you
anymore
you can come back to the bar no reason
why I like it is because from the
Belgian days you literally watch it like
this is gonna when you are about yeah it
just made you like oh my gosh
just leave it no can you please give
them out of here and it's just not your
job though what you do is what what are
the bells are sometimes coming to you're
the friend you come in and you the
bouncer hey you're doing good here keep
it down a little bit
indeed just come yo guys like when next
time I walk over there I'm gonna be nice
time
just come in kick them all out and I
hope you take them out it's really if so
shady we're shady we're kicking alright
that one's a great sketch Natasha what
do you pay
I picked sex detective oh it isn't
detective Chuck Vaughn detective Sally
Ferguson you could use a genius right
now Tom Samwell whatever god Sam whoa
whoa
Tommy I've got ourselves a hard case
here all we've got is two bodies both
dead naked one man one woman in the bed
two scented candles by the nightstand
how did you no sign of forced entry
he loved the way they smelled
he wanted to cross the threshold the way
they had on their wedding day dirty dog
he would have experienced that pleasure
right here anniversary a couple was
together for a while wanted to spice
things up check the date on the
photograph okay why did you pick I
personally have someone who loves like
this genre so I love crime dramas and
your sex freaks and I'm a big ol sex
well the internet actually brought us a
story today that I think we could use a
sex detective for Joey and show that
next photo this is a sexy squirrel we
need we need a sex detective to tell us
hey why that's bro got titties there's a
whole National Geographic article Oh I
translated it and it says like I was
looking for a squirrel but I found a
sexy one instead but then there's a
whole National Geographic article about
it I think it was just kind of like skin
falls that got caught in a weird moment
[Laughter]
continental breakfast aha a one
admission for the continental breakfast
you can just help yourself sir mmm
interesting European style
[Music]
When in Rome
the forbidden fruit well aren't you a
tiny plum well la-dee-da paper and
everything and who are you my little
friend not a spoon not a fork but
something in between a foot poon but
will you think of next
Germany last summer I took a long road
trip to from Denver to Seattle to
Portland with my old college friends and
we're like we're gonna rough it we're
gonna go camping and then like the first
night we went camping we all woke up we
were like wait I hate this and in the
morning my friend at the continental
breakfast and he just had his little
coffee when you had sleeping bags and
all that stuff and the tent but they
just like traveled with it yeah I think
there was one more night where like we
did sleep in like the forest but I slept
in the car and also like I had injured I
think I broke a rib by accident I can't
I never found out why'd you break the
rib back soon
I was I was my birthday and I was
dancing at a bar and I fell I broke a
rib in college because when I was a
freshman in our freshman dorm we did a
Fight Club because we were and this guy
named dance acts if you're watching this
who's a fencer so I've mentioned that
because he had martial arts training
he has about like 40 pounds on me and we
were like all right no punching in the
face it's the only rule fight and Dan
like immediately like took me by the
shoulders put me on the ground got his
knees
on my shoulders just pounding everyone
else watching was like okay I think this
is I had trouble breathing and like
walking up stairs was hard because it
hurts so bad but then separately like
later that week I had a cat scan because
I had some stress fractures from running
too much and so they put this like
radioactive liquid in your body so they
can see all the cracks in your bones and
so the doctor was like well you don't
have any cracks in your shins but how'd
you break your rib oh what's that you
know you have a broken rib right can't
talk about Fight Club
yeah these conversations come these are
real I did cocaine this weekend
international waters right so this has
been about what is the best Jordan Peele
character and in our last episode a lot
of people talk about this sketch prep
for Teri's and I think the mark of a
good character is that if you just read
it on page it would just be like wait
what is this but then it comes to life
like this it emote you who I got an idea
feel free to say no but can we switch
seats I will not take no for an answer
why that's the combat seat Jonathan
Livingston Seagull if you're gonna be in
a combat seat then you got to be willing
to blast up on some carries because the
great power comes great response
yes okay I just I just wanted some leg
room okay max legroom you get yours
meanwhile I'm gonna go hayden Panettiere
awesome Terri's especially when they get
froggy a baby maybe you are have to be
ready to kidnap a Terry I don't you
don't have to be ready to touch ya idea
I don't think that's necessary
absolutely you have to fireboard those
mother Jamis I don't even understand
what that means
do you trust me no I'll take the head of
the yes mine is that hair hat and are
those eyebrows real Oh what do you think
what do we think rapid fire I want it to
be real the left looks real the right
does not look real oh they definitely
covered though the eyebrows I mean you
can't shave the brows they don't come
back ha ha I think I'm brows alone
that's the best character I think I was
the annoying passenger scenario so I
once got to fly first class oh it was
correct it was very cool and I like got
bumped up and so they sat me next to
this like business man and I was like I
truly don't know what I'm doing so I
copied everything he did like every
order I was like I will have the exact
same thing and so I sure he was just
very I know it was like who is this
little girl
maybe you Jordan yes I do
okay so our shout out is from lakyn hair
Lind and they wrote Hannah's handjob
joke was on point
Hannah had a handjob joke about how Ryan
looked when he ate a ghost pepper candy
yesterday that seemed like you're
getting a handjob
he was shaking around like an idiot and
I called him out for it I wasn't on
panel I was back there but I got on
camera anyway the camera likes me you
were in the episode and I got shout out
by Jacob Jordan is like a four year old
but in the good ways thank you so much
for watching
tune in next week when we're gonna do
this again for keegan-michael key but
before we go I just want to give a quick
shout out to our DP and camera guy Nick
he's getting married tomorrow - Nora
[Applause]
takes a lot of people to make this show
we really appreciate you Nick thanks for
watching please like comment and
subscribe see you next time
[Laughter]
[Music]